I have no romance for any marketing or  business behavior and never will to the  day I die period and that's a very  important statement that so few in this  room actually deeply believe and if you  did then you would never disrespect  anything new that has 150 million active  monthly users like snapchat because it  doesn't have a click out function so you  can figure out what the conversion rate  is the reason I am going to make  billions that have made hundreds of  millions and the reason many in here  will make millions is because there's a  difference between sales and  transactions and brand and marketing if  you just realized it was in your best  financial interest to take 20 percent of  your monies and behaviors and learn new  things and learn them you would make so  much more success out of your businesses  you